hello uh good afternoon i can't talk as
much as as fast as rebecca so
i hope i cut down enough of my slides so
i can make it through the time um first
let me let me say that it's a great
opportunity thank you for the
opportunity to be here
it's great to see the both the
theoretical results and the real world
example uh what i'll do today is to um
also share with you one of our projects
on real-time aggregate monitoring with
differential privacy this is a joint
work with my student life and
the ufn and um professor my uh
collaborating pi vita syndrome
um so as katrina mentioned uh big data
have different dimensions one of the
dimension is the velocity
data is dynamic and they're changing
constantly one of the driving factors
that i think is the social media or
social sensing right people
constantly have smartphones gps devices
and they can contribute a lot of the
data they can collect a lot of data from
anywhere anytime does include
gps information gps location
their
symptoms they can report their physical
activities they can report and the smart
meters that are being installed at
different households that can monitor
the energy consumption and all that so
we've seen many of these applications
like traffic monitoring syndromic
surveillance and smart metering and so
on um so all these settings can be
abstracted into this sort of figure
where we have the individual data that
are being collected constantly
continuously into a trusted server and
then they want to mine or analyze these
aggregated time series data and share it
with researchers for other purposes
so here we want to address the privacy
of the personal data this includes the
location speed data household energy
consumption and all these
and of course one particular requirement
we want to address here is the real-time
requirement we want to do this online or
as the data are generated
as a quick outline
i'll just talk about a simplified
version of the problem which is single
aggregate monitoring and then move on to
multiple aggregate monitoring or spatial
temporal modeling monitoring and for
each of these problems i'll introduce
our algorithms and give some quick
empirical studies on real world data
sets not as big scale as rebecca's at t
data but these are some real-world data
sets that are publicly available
and at the end i'll try to give a quick
discussion and introduce some of our
work in progress
um so the simplified or the simplest
version of our problem is a single
aggregate time series monitoring problem
and here we have a univariate discrete
time series x which consists of a bunch
of values x sub k
at each different individual time points
here k is a discrete time index
varying from 0 to
big t and t is the length of our entire
time series that we want to monitor our
monitoring period
and these there we can see many examples
this x sub k can be the daily flow count
in the particular region or the hourly
traffic count at a particular
intersection on the map
so our problem is given this aggregate
time series notice that it's already
aggregated it's an aggregated count so
given this aggregate time series x and
the differential privacy budget alpha we
want to release alpha differential
private series with high utility so here
the privacy notion we use is the user
level privacy meaning each individual
user can contribute to each of the count
at each individual time points
so it's not it's different from the
event level privacy notion i'm sure
we'll hear in other talks
and here our utility is measured by the
relative error between the release time
series and the original time series at
each individual time points okay and um
later i'll just introduce quickly one of
the applications we use or we apply all
these release time series outbreak
detection so there we use a different
utility metric
so given this problem and given the
laplace mechanism we have heard from
katrina's tutorial one baseline approach
is
at each time point given the aggregated
time series value we can just apply a
laplace perturbation on the original
value so given the x sub k
we can draw a laplace noise and add it
onto the original value and release the
perturbed value and because we have t
time points and overall privacy budget
alpha so we have to divide alpha over
these t time points based on the
composition theorem sequential
composition theorem so each of the
perturbation gets the budget alpha over
t and as a result our release time
series would have a noise in order of t
big t
the total length of the time series so
that obviously is not a good idea the
amount of noise could be very large if
our time series is long
so um recently there's a work that's
been proposed it's called discrete
fourier transform approach so it's a
very smart idea where given the time
series if it's too high too
too much noise to perturb at each time
point then why don't we just transform
the data into the fourier using the
fourier transform into the time domain
and then we just perturb the
coefficients in the frequency domain
and once we so the the
approach
just applies the discrete fourier
transform on the aggregate time series
and then in the frequency domain we just
retain only d coefficients of that
so because of this we can actually just
uh perturb these these d coefficients
and then after that we do a
reconstruction and get the original time
series so now you can see now we would
have a perturbation error in the order
of d where d is much smaller than the
big t
and we would also have a reconstruction
error
so it shows in a paper that
even given these um trade-offs between
reconstruction error and perturbation
error the overall accuracy is still
better than the baseline approach so
questions what can be shown after just
doing the cropping of the um
coefficients
in the frequency domain
after we chop up the coefficients we
just do a reconstruction well that
itself doesn't have differential privacy
guarantee so is there a negative result
it's not a change oh because it's
interesting
yeah
well it's somewhat random but we can't
really prove that it's differentiate
private that's good
i'm sure we can cook up some bad
examples
some attacks yeah
um yes
if you're expecting the largest
coefficients that that depends the data
itself exactly exactly so that's another
argument we say here okay it's hard to
decide how many coefficients you keep
and that's very data dependent i just
think which ones they are also depends
which ones are yes exactly so that's
that's um
that's some of the limitations of this
work and in addition to these
limitations we also argue that this kind
of approach can be only applied offline
or in a batch processing mode where you
would have to have a
period of the time series in order to do
transformation and reconstruction in
order to be meaningful
so in our approach what we propose is a
um
approach we call fast filtering and
adaptive sampling aggregate time series
monitoring there are basically two ideas
the first one is called filtering it's
really a post-processing technique that
given the basic laplace mechanism we
want to do some post-processing or some
filtering to get a better educated guess
of the original true value so that's the
first idea and the second idea is the
adaptive sampling which is also very
intuitive very straightforward since
it's too
much noise to be added to add to every
single time point so why don't we do
sampling we can just sample selected
time points and do the perturbation but
of course the problem is which time
points to sample and how do we sample so
that's our adaptive sampling idea where
we use the feedback to actually help us
decide the sampling rate
so this is the overall figure of the
approach we have aggregated data coming
in and it goes through a plus
perturbation mechanism the baseline um
you can think of it as the baseline the
basic laplace perturbation and the
perturbed value would go through a
filtering component where we have a
prediction and correction step
um prediction assumes there's an
underlying model of the time series so
this is a model based approach where we
assume there's an underlying process
model for the data and use the
prediction we can get a prior estimate
of the next time point and then
if we are at a sampling point we would
get a perturbed time time value or a
observed noisy data value and using that
we would correct it and get a posterior
estimate and release that okay
and then since we have the prior
estimate and posterior estimate then we
would take the difference and treat that
as an error or as a feedback and
feed it back to the sampling
adjustment component help us to adjust
our sampling rate so the basic idea is
if the prior and posterior they differ a
lot that means the model is not very
accurate in terms of helping us
predicting the data value so we need to
sample more frequently otherwise if the
error is small that means the model is
very accurate so we don't need to
increase our sampling rate rather we
would actually decrease our sampling
rate and save the budget for other more
dynamic time points
so that's the overall picture i'll just
get into a little bit detail of each of
the
idea so for the filtering
we would assume a process model that
generates the underlying time series so
here is our underlying process x sub k
and the next high point is x sub k plus
1 and to start with we have a very
simplified constant model or linear
model where we say the value at time
point x sub k plus 1 is only dependent
on the value of the previous time point
k
which plus a
white noise and the white noise is just
a gaussian noise with a
variance q
so this is our process model and given
the x sub k since it goes through the
laplace perturbation and what we observe
is z sub k which is uh differentially
private so that's our measurement model
uh given the x sub k we're adding a
laplace noise and gets the z sub k so
now our real question in terms of the
post processing is given this noisy
measurement z sub k how do we estimate
the true state the true value x sub k so
it becomes the estimation problem
um and we can apply some basic bayesian
rules and all that and it turns out
the posterior distribution or the
posterior distribution of the x sub k
which is our estimation problem
if
it's a basic formula here the the only
issue is that our likelihood function
given the x sub k what's the probability
of
observing z sub k this function is
laplace noise okay so this becomes a
little difficult if it's gaussian it
becomes very easy to compute
analytically however it's laplace noise
so it becomes difficult to compute
so we have
proposed two options or export two
options the first one is okay let's just
approximate the noise as
gaussian noise so notice here that the
noise that are injected into the data is
still a plus it's just in the modeling
or post-processing we're approximated
using a gaussian form so that we can
apply the common filter the traditional
common filter approach to uh do the
filtering and to do the posterior
estimate and another option is we use
the multi-color simulations to estimate
the posterior density using the sampling
importance resampling approach so both
of these two approaches we experimented
with them
and these are some details of the two
approaches i'm just going to skip them
so that's the filter approach and the
second idea was the adaptive sampling as
i mentioned this just illustrates the
idea if the data is fairly constant we
want to keep the sampling rate low
however if the data is going through a
lot of changes we want to increase our
sampling rate and get more observations
so how do we control this
the idea is using the feedback error
since we have the prior estimate based
on our model based on the process model
and if we do get a
observed noisy value we will have a
posterior estimate using the either
common filter or the um particle filter
then we can compute the difference or
the area between the prior and posterior
and we can use that as our feedback
error and we use the basic pid
controller which computes the
proportional the current error and the
integral error and the derivative error
and combining these three we have these
adjustment formula which will determine
a new sampling interval based on the
error and again the basic idea is the
area is if if the error is large then we
increase the sampling interval
i'm sorry increasing the sampling
frequency and decrease the sampling
interval
so those are the two basic ideas and we
did some evaluation on
both synthetic data sets and real data
sets the synthetic data says we have
linearly generated data and logistic
data and sinusoidal data the
main motivation to try these different
data sets is that since this is a model
based approach our process model is
assuming a linear model so we might want
to see if the data is indeed generated
by a linear model then the approach may
work better than the data that are not
generated by the linear model
we also tested it with several real
world data sets these include the flu
data sets from the cdc collected over a
several year period including 209 data
points and the traffic data from the
university of washington intelligence
transportation systems research between
2003 and 2004 and another unemployment
data sets these two figures just shows
or illustrates how the data look like
they do have different dynamics
um this one illustrates the
effect of the baseline laplace mechanism
and our approach so the blue line shows
the original time series data
and the dashed line shows the time
series released by the baseline lpa
mechanism and you can see it adds a lot
of noise because it has notice at each
individual time points based on the
sensitivity and our fast approach
because of the
filtering the post processing and
adaptive sampling it was able to
reconstruct or
gets much closer to the original time
series the release
data
and you can see this flat lines is
actually the
the effect or the result of the adaptive
sampling what's the frequency of the
data
the frequency of the data set um what do
you mean different data sets have
different frequencies
um the frequency of the timestamp that
you're having
for each there
um okay so that's a good question for
this one i believe it's the flu data set
or i believe it's the flu data set then
it will be hourly uh not hourly daily
flow counts
so like every day
but now i have a double check on that i
can't get back to if i missed it
we also did some more experiments using
different data sets so this one compares
the result of kalman filter and particle
filter for different data sets so the
immediate thing we can see is that the
logistic data and sinusoidal data have a
much higher relative error than the
linear data
this sort of confirms our hypothesis or
our guess that if the data is not
generated by the linear model
or it doesn't fit with your assumed data
model then it doesn't work as well so in
this case one of the conclusion we had
is actually well any domain knowledge
would be helpful if you know your data
the underlying model of your data then
you can do much better things otherwise
if you're just kind of randomly testing
your model then it may not work as
effectively but fortunately for these
real-world data sets it works
surprisingly well
for these food data traffic data and
employment data
even though we don't exactly know the
underlying model of this data but by
approximating this linear model it works
extremely well
and another quick takeaway is that the
particle filter
is slightly more robust than the common
filter because we don't need to tune the
parameters however it does take more
time it's more time consuming because of
the simulation process
this compares to fixed sampling and
adaptive sampling
the two lines that has a dip basically
shows with different sampling intervals
we were able to achieve different
results and which is very intuitive
because the trade-off between the
perturbation error and sampling error
but with our adaptive sampling it works
independently from the sampling interval
and it's actually able to achieving
almost optimal results that can be
achieved by the
fixed sampling
this shows the utility versus the
different level of privacy
for different data sets also in
comparison with the baseline lpa
approach and the discrete fourier
transform approach
so the basic uh message here is that the
fast approach works fairly reasonably
well but one interesting factor is here
is that when the alpha value the
differential privacy parameter is
sufficiently high the lpa approach is
actually good
um
so that's surprising both surprising and
not surprising yes
so questions many levels do it return
requirements or which one
for your transformation oh the dft we
use the we use uh the number that's
recommended by the paper
but it varies for the data sets
the relative error is actually for
example here is 1 and here is actually
10. so
this is pretty uh frustrating right by
looking at the absolute value of these
errors
we feel like okay does it really work
the error is actually 100 for example
when it's one
which is understandable because we have
200 time points we have to divide the
budget of 1 or 0.1 into these 100 time
points
um
so this
it's it i don't know whether we should
characterize this as negative result or
positive result but
the absolute the average relative error
is fairly high however
what i want to show next is that despite
this error which seemingly is high
if we are using this data for outbreak
detection in fact for all these
different data sets our f1 metric which
is a combination of the precision recall
is reasonably
good
for example for this flu data set we're
able to achieve 75
or 0.0
0.7 for the f1 score um
so i think that's that's a good message
meaning if we simply look at the error
or the absolute error or the relative
error it may be really very high but
depending on what we want to do with the
data for example we want to do the
outbreak detection which is defined by a
certain increase in the data value in a
time series then we may actually get
good utility from the data
then we extended this work into
multi-dimensional time series with
spatial temporal data where we not only
want to monitor the aggregates for one
single cell we may want to monitor the
traffic counts for all the intersections
on the map for example
so we took two approaches temporal
modeling and spatial partitioning and
the temporal modeling is very simple we
just treat each single intersection as
one single time series over time and
just apply the previous approaches but
of course we did some network road
network based modeling for the variants
so we also did the multivariate time
series modeling using the markup models
and another interesting angle is we can
also do the space partitioning sort of
considering the spatial
dimension of the network of the road
network our first idea is why don't we
apply the feedback driven sort of
dynamic control on our
space partition spatial partitioning
right if the data is going through a lot
of changes we may want to drill down
into the area if the data is sort of
constant then we can afford to go up
and we try to apply this dynamic
partitioning idea and we failed
miserably and we're not able to get any
good result using the dynamic
partitioning and our guess is that or
our sort of conclusion is that because
of the noisy data we're using the noise
data to do the control to do the
decision on the dynamic partitioning and
the guidance is just not as good as not
doing the partition or dynamic
partitioning so our we had to resort to
sort of road network based quad tree
partitioning or basic partition static
partitioning
and we were able to get some good
results in this sense
so as a quick discussion um or some
quick work in progress this consider my
rom session submission since i won't be
here tomorrow
we realized that the differentially
private monitoring sort of continuous
publishing of dynamic data or time
series data is a difficult problem
especially when the time series is long
or if we want to do it forever
or when the data is sparse however a
lesson we learned is that any kind of
domain knowledge the model that might be
used that might be that we might know to
generate underlying data or um the road
network that we can use to help us
partition the space any of these domain
knowledge could be useful for temporary
and spatial modeling um and a related
question that rebecca also brought up is
the dynamic budget allocation so in a
static case you want to allocate a
budget among different steps but here
for the dynamic case we also want to
decide how to allocate a budget for
different time points even if we have
the sampling
for different sampling points how do we
dynamically allocate a budget that's a
sort of online resource allocation very
difficult problem
and we're also working on a
distance-based approach which sort of uh
similar or related to that um what
katrina has mentioned um instead of the
model based approach and finally we're
also interested in looking at
correlating data from multiple uh
sources or multiple time series
with that i'll thank
um you fast i didn't understand how you
were
doing the adapting in a differentially
private way
the adapting is actually um already
differentially private because we're not
using original data to do the adapting
i'm sorry then
what's telling you to change your rate
yeah so we're using two the first one is
a prior estimate which is used purely
based on the process model
so using the observed value or possible
estimate from the last point we can
predict the next point value so that's a
prior estimate
and then if we have an observed value
which is noisy which is differentiate
private and then we do a posterior
estimate and then the difference between
these two we use this as a feedback
arrow yeah thank you
yes
because you consider mainly
counting data and they are positive and
discrete so how about using some other
more
directly relevant models like awesome
model
for for the
predictive distribution other than the
gaussian model economy
right so that's a very good question but
here our model is actually um
modeling the change from the last point
to this point
when you're saying poison model it's um
i have to well
yeah
so that's exactly yeah so it's not on
the aggregate counts i think but on the
other hand related to that we are
actually applying some more um
complex models
so using adaptive common filter instead
of the linear model
thank you